Y descubrí muy pronto que no estaba solo:
resulta que más del 80 % de las personas de su entorno
no disfrutan de su trabajo.
Supongo que aquí es diferente,
pero ese es el promedio que Deloitte ha encontrado en sus estudios.
así que quería saber, qué diferencia a esta gente,
que hace con pasión, el trabajo de cambiar el mundo,
que despierta inspirada cada día,
de estas personas, el otro 80 %
que llevan vidas de silenciosa desesperación.
Así, entrevisté a estas personas que hacen este trabajo inspirador,
y leí libros e hice estudios de caso,
300 libros sobre propósito y carrera y todo esto
una autoinmersión total, realmente por la razón egoísta de...
quería encontrar el trabajo que no podía dejar de hacer,
el que era para mí.
Y al hacerlo, más y más gente comenzó a preguntarme,
"Estás en temas de carrera.
No me gusta mi trabajo. ¿Podemos almorzar?".
Yo: "Claro". Pero tenía que advertirles,
que entonces, mi tasa de abandono era también de 80 %.
El 80 % de las personas con las que almorcé, dejaron su trabajo
en el plazo de dos meses.
Estaba orgulloso de esto y no tenía ninguna magia especial.
Hacía una pregunta simple:
"¿Por qué haces el trabajo que haces?".
Y muy a menudo su respuesta era,
"Porque alguien me dijo que debía hacerlo".
Y me di cuenta de que muchas personas
suben por la escalera que alguien les indica subir,
y terminan apoyando la escalera contra la pared equivocada,
o en ninguna pared.
Conforme pasaba tiempo con ellas y veía el problema,
pensaba, ¿qué pasaría si creábamos una comunidad,
donde se tuviera sentido de pertenencia y donde
estuviera bien hacer las cosas de otra manera,
tomar el camino menos transitado,
donde animar e inspirar a la gente a cambiar?
Y más tarde esto se convirtió en lo que llamo Vive tu leyenda,
que explicaré un poco.
Pero conforme hacía estos descubrimientos, me di cuenta de un marco
de 3 cosas realmente simples
que todos estos trasformadores de mundo apasionados tienen en común,
seas un Steve Jobs o seas solo, ya sabes,
la persona que tiene la panadería de la esquina.
Pero haces el trabajo que plasma lo que eres.
Quiero compartir los tres, para utilizarlos como una lente
para el resto del día y espero del resto de nuestra vida.
La primera parte de este marco de trabajo de tres pasos
es convertirse en un autoexperto y comprenderse a uno mismo
porque si no se sabe lo que busca,
nunca lo encontrará.
Y el punto es que nadie hará esto por nosotros.
No hay título universitario en pasión y propósito y carrera.
No sé cómo no es una doble licenciatura requerida,
pero ni se ha intentado.
O sea, que se pasa más tiempo escogiendo un mueble para la TV
que eligiendo la materia de estudios.
Pero está en nosotros darnos cuenta de eso,
y necesitamos un marco, una forma de navegar a través de eso.
Y el primer paso es averiguar cuáles son nuestros puntos fuertes.
¿Qué cosas deseamos hacer al despertarnos no importa qué,
si nos pagan o no, qué cosas que la gente nos agradece?
'Conozca sus Fortalezas 2.0' es un libro y una herramienta en línea.
Lo recomiendo para clasificar en lo que son buenos por naturaleza.
Y después, ¿cuál es el marco o jerarquía para la toma de decisiones?
¿Nos preocupamos por las personas, la familia, la salud,
o se trata de logro, éxito, y esas cosas?
Debemos averiguar qué es para tomar estas decisiones,
así sabremos de qué está hecha nuestra alma,
para no ir a vendernos a cualquier causa que no nos va a importar nada.
Y a continuación, el siguiente paso, nuestras experiencias.
Todos tenemos experiencias. Aprendemos cosas cada día y minuto
sobre lo que amamos, lo que nos gusta,
en qué somos buenos, en qué fatales.
Y si no pasamos tiempo prestando atención a esto
y asimilando el aprendizaje
y su aplicación al resto de nuestra vida, es todo para nada.
Cada día, cada semana, cada mes de cada año
paso un tiempo reflexionando sobre lo que salió bien,
lo que salió mal, y lo que quiero repetir,
¿qué puedo aplicar a mi vida?
Y aún más que eso, conforme se ve a la gente, sobre todo hoy,
quién te inspira, quién hace cosas que uno dice
"Dios, lo que hace Jeff, quiero ser como él".
¿Por qué lo dicen? Abran un diario.
Escriban qué es y qué los inspira.
No va a ser todo sobre sus vidas,
pero sea lo que sea, tomen nota,
con el tiempo tendremos este repositorio de cosas
que podremos aplicar a nuestra vida y tener una existencia más apasionada
y tener un mayor impacto.
Porque al empezar a poner estas cosas juntas,
podemos definir qué significa en realidad el éxito para nosotros,
y sin estas diferentes partes de la brújula, es imposible.
Acabamos en la situación... Tenemos el guion de vida
que todos parecen vivir, subiendo la escalera a ninguna parte.
Es un poco como en Wall Street 2, si alguien la vio,
el empleado peón pregunta al gran CEO banquero de Wall Street,
"¿Cuál es su número? Todo el mundo tiene un número,
que si llega a ese dinero, lo dejaría todo".
Él dice: "Oh, es muy sencillo. Más".
Y solo sonríe.
Y es el triste estado de la mayoría
que no ha invertido tiempo en entender lo que les importa,
que intenta alcanzar algo que no significa nada,
pero lo hacemos porque se supone que hay que hacerlo.
Pero con este marco,
podemos empezar a identificar las cosas que nos hacen cobrar vida.
Antes de esto, una pasión podía llegar y golpearlo en su cara
o tal vez en su sector, quizá la habría desechado
porque uno no tiene forma de identificarla.
Pero una vez lo hace, se puede ver algo congruente con mis puntos fuertes,
mis valores, lo que soy como persona,
así que entraré en esto, haré algo con esto,
y seguiré e intentaré tener un impacto con ello.
Vive tu leyenda y el movimiento que hemos construido
no existirían sin esta brújula para identificar
"Esto es algo que quiero perseguir y marcar una diferencia".
Si no sabemos lo que buscamos, nunca lo vamos a encontrar,
pero una vez que tengamos este marco, esta brújula,
entonces podemos pasar a lo siguiente,
haciendo lo imposible y llevándolo al límite.
Por dos razones la gente no hace cosas.
Una: se dicen a sí mismos que no pueden
o las personas de su entorno se lo dicen.
Como sea, nos lo creemos.
O nos damos por vencidos o nunca empezamos.
Las cosas son imposibles hasta que alguien las hace.
Cada invento, cada nueva cosa en el mundo,
la gente pensaba al principio que estaban locos.
Roger Bannister y la milla en 4 minutos, era un imposible físico
hacer la milla en cuatro minutos en una carrera
hasta que Roger Bannister lo hizo.
Y entonces, ¿qué pasó?
Dos meses después, 16 personas hicieron lo mismo.
Las cosas que pensamos que son imposibles
son a menudo solo hitos esperando a lograrse
si podemos empujar esos límites un poco.
Y creo que esto comienza con, probablemente, el cuerpo físico
más que nada, porque eso lo podemos controlar.
Si uno no cree que pueda correr una milla,
se muestra a sí mismo que puede correr 1 o 2,
o un maratón o perder peso, o lo que sea,
se da cuenta de los elementos de confianza
y puede transferirlos al resto de su mundo.
He involucrado en el hábito de esto a mis amigos.
Tenemos este grupito. Y nos vamos de aventuras físicas,
y recientemente, me encontré en un punto precario.
Tengo terror al agua azul, oscura y profunda.
No sé si alguien ha tenido ese mismo miedo
desde que vieron Tiburón 1, 2, 3 y 4 como seis veces
de niños.
Pero cualquier cosa aquí, si es turbia, puedo sentir miedo.
Juro que hay algo ahí dentro.
Incluso en el lago Tahoe, que es de agua dulce, miedo infundado,
ridículo, pero está ahí.
Hace tres años me vi en este remolcador
aquí en la Bahía de San Francisco.
Es un día lluvioso, ventoso, y la gente estaba enfermando en el barco,
y yo sentado con un traje de neopreno, miraba por la ventana
aterrorizado pensaba que iba a nadar hacia mi muerte.
Iba a tratar de nadar a través del Golden Gate.
Puede que algunas personas aquí lo hayan hecho antes.
Sentado allí, mi amigo Jonathan, que me había hablado de esto,
vino a mí y vio el estado en el que me encontraba.
Y dijo: "Scott, hombre, ¿qué es lo peor que puede pasar?
Llevas un traje de neopreno. No te hundirás.
Y si no lo logras, simplemente subes a uno de los 20 kayaks.
Además, si hay un ataque de tiburón, ¿por qué te escogería
entre las 80 personas del agua?". Gracias, gran ayuda.
Y él "Simplemente diviértete. Buena suerte".
Y se sumerge y se va nadando.
Resulta que la charla funcionó totalmente y sentí esta sensación de calma absoluta,
creo que fue porque Jonathan tenía 13 años.
(Risas)
De las 80 personas que nadaban ese día,
65 oscilaban entre las edades de 9 y 13.
Piensen cómo habrían enfrentado su mundo de otra manera
si a los 9 años supieran que podían nadar una milla y media
en agua a 13 º C desde Alcatraz hasta San Francisco.
¿A qué le habrían dicho sí?
¿A qué no habrían renunciado? ¿Qué habrían intentado?
Cuando acabé este nado, salí del Parque Acuático,
y ya fuera del agua
la mitad de los niños ya habían terminado,
y me animaban y todos estaban emocionados.
Y ya a esta altura, si alguien ha nadado en la bahía,
intentaba simplemente descongelar mi cara, viendo terminar a los demás.
Y vi a un niño, algo que no se veía bien.
Él solo se agitaba así.
Y apenas lograba tomar algo de aire al sacar la cabeza.
Y vi que otros padres lo veían también,
y juro que pensaban lo mismo que yo:
así no se debe dejar nadar a los de 9 años desde Alcatraz.
No era la fatiga.
De repente, dos padres lo alzan y lo agarran,
y lo ponen sobre sus hombros, y lo llevan así,
totalmente flácido.
Y luego, de repente, caminan unos metros más
y lo dejan en su silla de ruedas.
Y pone sus puños de victoria más increíbles que haya visto nunca.
Todavía puedo sentir el calor y la energía de este joven
al conseguir este logro.
Yo lo había visto ese mismo día en su silla de ruedas.
No tenía ni idea de que iba a nadar.
Quiero decir, ¿a dónde llegará en 20 años?
¿Cuánta gente dijo que no podría hacerlo, que moriría si lo intentaba?
Uno ve que la gente se equivoca, que uno se equivoca,
que puede lograr pequeños avances
de lo que cree que es posible.
Uno no tiene que ser el corredor más rápido del mundo,
simplemente con las propias imposibilidades, lograr cosas
y comenzar con pequeños pasos.
Y la mejor manera de hacerlo
es rodearse de gente apasionada.
Lo más rápido para hacer cosas que uno no piensa que puede hacer
es rodearse de personas que ya lo están haciendo.
Hay una cita de Jim Rohn que dice:
"Eres es el promedio de las cinco personas con las que pasas más tiempo".
No hay atajo productivo más grande en la historia del mundo
para llegar de donde está hoy a donde quiere estar,
que la gente que elige para poner en su esquina.
Cambian todo, y es un hecho probado.
En 1898, Norman Triplett hizo este estudio con un grupo de ciclistas,
y midió sus vueltas a la pista en grupo,
e individualmente.
Y encontró cada vez que los ciclistas en grupo lo hacían más rápido.
Se ha repetido en todo tipo de ámbitos de la vida, desde entonces,
y se demuestra lo mismo,
que las personas que te rodean importan, y el ambiente lo es todo.
Pero está en uno controlarlo, porque puede ir en ambos sentidos.
El 80 % de los que no les gusta su trabajo,
la mayoría de quienes nos rodean, no aquí, pero en todas partes,
son alentadores complacientes y nos impiden buscar las cosas que nos importan
así que tenemos que manejar esos alrededores.
Me encontré en esta situación...
ejemplo personal, hace un par de años.
¿Alguien ha tenido un hobby o una pasión que inundó su corazón y alma,
increíble cantidad de tiempo, y tan mal quieren llamarlo un negocio,
pero nadie está prestando atención y no hacen ni un centavo?
Yo estuve allí por 4 años tratando de construir este movimiento Vive tu leyenda
para ayudar a la gente a trabajar en lo que realmente les importa e inspira,
y haciendo todo lo que podía,
y solo 3 personas ponían atención,
y todos están ahí: mi madre, mi padre y mi esposa, Chelsea.
Gracias por el apoyo.
(Aplausos)
Y lo que tan ardientemente quería, creció 0 % durante 4 años,
y yo estaba a punto de apagarlo,
y justo entonces,
me mudé a San Francisco y empecé a conocer a personas muy interesantes
que tenían locos estilos de vida de aventura,
de empresas y sitios web y blogs
rodeadas por sus pasiones y ayudaban a la gente de una manera significativa.
Y uno de mis amigos, bueno, tiene una familia de ocho,
y apoya toda su familia
con un blog que escribe dos veces por semana.
Acaban de volver de un mes en Europa, todos ellos juntos.
Quedé alucinado. ¿Cómo es que existe?
Y me inspiré increíblemente viendo esto,
y en vez de apagarlo, decidí, vamos a tomarlo en serio.
E hice todo lo que pude para usar mi tiempo,
cada hora de vigilia posible persiguiéndolos,
pasar el rato, unas cervezas, entrenamientos, lo que fuera.
Y después de 4 años de crecimiento 0,
en 6 meses dando vueltas con estas personas,
la comunidad Vive tu leyenda creció 10 veces.
En otros 12 meses, creció 160 veces.
Y hoy en día más de 30 000 personas de 158 países
utilizan nuestras herramientas de carrera mensualmente.
Y esas personas han hecho esta comunidad de gente apasionada
que inspiró esa posibilidad que soñé
para Vive tu leyenda tantos años atrás.
Las personas cambian todo, y es por eso...
saben, uno se pregunta lo que estaba pasando.
Desde hace 4 años, no conocía a nadie en este espacio,
y ni siquiera sabía que existía, que la gente pudiera hacer estas cosas,
que uno podría tener movimientos como este.
Entonces yo aquí en San Francisco, y todos a mi alrededor lo estaban haciendo.
Se convirtió en normal, y mi pensamiento pasó de cómo podría yo hacer esto
a cómo era posible no hacerlo.
Y, cuando eso sucede, que el interruptor cambia en tu cabeza,
repercute en todo tu mundo.
Y sin siquiera intentarlo, tus estándares van de aquí a aquí.
No necesitas cambiar tus metas. Solo tienes que cambiar tu entorno.
Es todo, y es por eso que me encanta estar cerca de este grupo de personas,
por lo que voy a cada TED que pueda,
y verlas en mi iPad camino al trabajo, sea lo que sea.
Porque este es el grupo de personas que inspira posibilidad.
Tenemos todo un día para estar juntos y mucho más.
Para acabar, en términos de estos tres pilares,
todos ellos tienen una cosa en común más que otra cosa.
Están 100 % en nuestro control.
Nadie puede decirte que no puedes aprender de ti mismo.
Nadie puede decirte que no puedes empujar tus límites
y aprender tu propio imposible y empujarlo.
Nadie puede decirte que no puedes rodearte de personas que inspiran
o alejarte de las que lo depriman.
No puedes controlar una recesión.
No puedes controlar ser despedido o tener un accidente de coche.
La mayoría de cosas están totalmente fuera de nuestras manos.
Estas tres cosas dependen totalmente de nosotros,
y pueden cambiar todo nuestro mundo si nos decidimos a hacer algo al respecto.
Y está empezando a suceder en un nivel generalizado.
Acabo de leer en Forbes, el Gobierno informó que por primera vez
en un mes más personas habían dejado sus trabajos
que las que habían sido despedidas.
Pensaron que era una anomalía, pero ha pasado tres meses seguidos.
En una época en que la gente dice que el entorno es difícil,
que están dando un dedo medio a esta vida con guion,
las cosas que la gente dice que se supone que hacer,
a cambio de cosas que son importantes para ellos y que los inspiran.
Y el punto es que la gente está tomando conciencia de esta posibilidad,
que realmente lo único que limita la posibilidad ahora es la imaginación.
Esto no es un cliché más.
No me importa qué es lo que te gusta, qué pasión, qué manía.
Si haces punto, puedes encontrar a alguien que se mata por hacer punto,
y puedes aprender de ella. Es salvaje.
Y de eso es de lo que se trata todo el día, de aprender de los que hablan,
y perfilamos estas personas en Vive tu leyenda todos los días,
porque cuando la gente común hace lo extraordinario,
y podemos rodearlos,
se vuelve normal.
No se trata de ser Gandhi o Steve Jobs, haciendo algo loco.
Se trata solo de hacer algo que te importe,
y tener un impacto que solo tú puedes hacer.
Hablando de Gandhi, era abogado en recuperación,
como he oído el término,
y fue llamado a una causa mayor, algo que le importaba,
no podía no hacerlo.
Él tiene esta cita que comparto completamente.
"Primero te ignoran, luego se ríen de ti,
después te atacan, luego ganas".
Todo era imposible hasta que alguien lo hizo.
Puedes colgarte en torno a personas que dicen que no se puede hacer
y decirte que eres estúpido por tratar,
o rodearte de las personas que inspiran posibilidad,
las personas que están en esta sala.
Porque lo veo como nuestra responsabilidad mostrar al mundo
que lo que se ve como imposible puede convertirse en ese nuevo normal.
Y que ya está empezando a suceder.
En primer lugar, hacer las cosas que nos inspiran,
para que podamos inspirar a otras personas a hacer las cosas que les inspira.
Pero no podemos encontrarlo
si no sabemos lo que estamos buscando.
Tenemos que hacer nuestro trabajo en nosotros,
ser intencionales en ello, y hacer esos descubrimientos.
Porque me imagino un mundo donde al 80 %
de la gente le encante el trabajo que hace.
¿Cómo se vería eso?
¿Cuál sería la innovación? ¿Cómo tratar a las personas que te rodean?
Las cosas empiezan a cambiar.
Y para acabar, solo tengo una pregunta
y creo que es la única pregunta que importa.
Y es ¿qué trabajo no puedes dejar de hacer?
Descúbrelo, vívelo,
no solo para ti, sino para todo el mundo que te rodea,
porque eso es lo que empieza a cambiar el mundo.
¿Cuál es el trabajo que no puedes dejar de hacer?
Gracias chicos.
(Aplausos)